notre vol était de kaboul
au
koweït et du koweït juste
à l'allemagne juste au moment où nous sommes arrivés ici, cela
prend environ six heures
dans les premières,
nous sommes environ 800 personnes
quand ils savent que
je suis un interprète, puis
ils ont utilisé
une mauvaise langue pour moi et ils m'ont battu
aussi
misoko nous sommes heureux nous apprécions tous
de
la toujours coopération du gouvernement canadien
qu'ils obtiennent toujours
leur soutien pour nous
donc nous nous sentons heureux
nous sommes en sécurité maintenant nous allons bien
merci nous attendons les
gars canadiens nous tournons nos documents
[Musique]
étranger